لمن توجه نشرات اعدادها الى 90 ثانيه قبل
منتصف الليل او ثلاث دقائق او تسعين او
مئه ثانيه كما كانت في عام 2021 هل توجه
الى الزعماء الى الرؤساء اما انه المفهوم
يتعلق فقط على المستوى المستوى البشريه
بشكل عام في العالم
المفهوم مرتبط
بالانسانيه جمعاء ولكنها تركز بشكل اساسي
اللي نشري الوعي لاصحاب القرار واصحاب
القرار نقصد بذلك في كل دول العالم كل دول
الان
تواجه الصعوبات المرتبطه بازمه المناخ
وكذلك صعوبات مرتبطه بالجائحه
واذا ما حصلت كارثه نوويه
فاثارها بالتاكيد ستكون عالميا
وحيا الساعه رمزيه
اليوم هو مثل بناء اليقظه
هذه التسعون ثانيه قريبه جدا من منتصف
الليل في عام 91 وفي نهايه الحرب البارده
فالنساها عدت الى 17 ثانيه فقط من منتصف
الليل
او سبعه عشر دقيقه اما فيما يخص 1920
فكانت ابعد بكثير اما الان فهي قريبه جدا
من منتصف الليل بعشره اضعافها فقط 90
ثانيه من منتصف الليل
لو تعيد لي فقط التحديثات التي اعلنتموها
اليوم هل مساله 90 ثانيه قبل ثانيه عشر
منتصف اليوم مساله نهائيه هل اقتربنا من
هذا اليوم وما هي الاسباب حقيقه وراء هذه
التحديثات اللي تم الاعلان عنها
الاسباب وراء هذه التحديثات هي التهديدات
الوجوديه
المرتبطه بالاسلحه النوويه
والكوارثه المناخيه
كما ان هنالك التقنيات التخريبيه
فمثلا الذكاء الاصطناعي فهذا يذكر الجميع
مدى قربنا من يوم القيامه او الهلاك وكل
اصحاب القرار عليهم ان يتذكروا دائما ذلك
وعندما يتاملون
هذا الوقت الضيق فسوف يتخذون القرارات
الجيده على سبيل المثال خلال الجائحه
عندما قدموا اللقاحات الجديده
وعندما
تظافر جهود العالم في الحقيقه تمكنا من
منع العديد من الوفيات والكثير من الاشياء
سلبيه
جنبا الى جنبي مع العلماء ومع الباحثين
نستطيع
ان نجعل قراراتنا اكثر ودقه